can understand why the small boat
situation gets so much attention it's
very dramatic it makes good TV all these
people getting off the dinghies and
bunged onto these tiny boats it's filmic
but that's not where the numbers are
the problem is legal immigration the
home office is letting in huge numbers
of people and the figures
the figures also don't include things
like Visa over stairs and people who
come through the airport and and say
they're here on tourist visas and then
just disappear we have no idea how many
of those people are
and that's so much easier than getting
into a dinghy
I bet there there are far more Visa over
stairs than there are migrants in small
boats